Did you know that once, a part of Kale's
questline had you looking around for a bird,
with a letter strapped to its leg?
Have you seen a crow around here by any chance?
You know, a burial crow,
with a letter fastened to its claw?
I'll give you a generous sum for it, of course.
And down here, we can find it. A
so-called "Burial Crow".
And if you kill it, you can
loot the "Burial Crow's Letter".
Which progresses Kale's questline,
helping him to locate the underground area
where his brothers were entombed, long ago.
This event in particular is a restoration of
Kale's cut questline, and if you'd like to see
the full thing, then Sekiro Dubi has a full
restoration of it, over on their channel.
But it's not just the questline that might relate to the burial crows:you know those notes that
you usually buy from merchants,
that give you hints about the world?
Well according to some version 1.0 text,
it's also possible that hunting
burial crows was originally the
method by which you were supposed to loot these notes.
And while we're speaking about the merchants, did you know that at one point,
there was planned to be a travelling merchant
who actually wandered around the map in Limgrave?
According to Sekiro Dubi, evidence that merchants
actually traveled survives in the
unused "walkroutes" that are found
in a couple of Elden Ring's maps.
For example, this is NPC 802,
who could be found here on the western coast..
before setting up camp here, by the bridge of
sacrifice south of the evergaol...
Then here in the mistwood...
and finally at Stormhill,
near the Saint's bridge.
To be clear, NPC 802 is an earlier type of
merchant - one that actually had much deeper lore,
at the time. As the story goes, this merchant is
actually aware of the dungeon underneath Leyndell
where his brothers are entombed, and wanders
around out of fear. Fear of staying in the
same place, and being locked up like his kin.
It's great storytelling, and it's a shame it
So one of the best strategies for taking out the
Godskin Duo - is sleep. It takes one
godskin out of commission entirely,
allowing the fight to become more of a 1 on 1.
But did you know that the Godskin are actually
supposed to be able to wake eachother up? This
isn't even cut content. There's actually just
a bug that prevents this interaction
from taking place, most of the time.
As far as I can tell, this was first
noted by LilAggy, while they were
doing a randomised race through Elden Ring.
And then in a comment thread begun by Ziostorm,
everyone got to work uncovering the truth.
According to this twitter user, the Godskin
boss is actually able to perform this scream
in the Windmill Village, if they're lured down
the hill where a celebrant is asleep.
So why doesn't it work in the Godskin arena?
Well according to @thefifthmatt, the Godskin AI
is supposed to do this if a "friend" is asleep,
but the friend detection is bugged out in
this arena because of the knights that patrol
outside the arena. So if, and only if, you remove
every single knight patrolling around the arena,
as well as the "hidden HP bar enemy",
it will work in their arena again.
This might explain why the waking behaviour
works in boss randomisers. A lot of these end
up with you fighting the Godskin duo outside
of their arena, so there aren't any patrolling
enemies to bug out this intended effect.
As for a lore explanation..well, sleep and death
do seem to overlap somewhat, as I discussed in my
Miquella lore video..so it makes some sense that
the Godskins, being deeply aware of death, might
have developed away to wake eachother out of it.
Speaking of death, did you know that some
of Those Who Live in Death..can do this?
Some things are just better
without any explanation, you know?
What also doesn't need any further explanation
at this point, is just how inspired From
Software are by Kentaro Miura's berserk.
But just when you think you've seen every
Berserk reference possible, another
reading reveals another reference.
I was reading this panel, in chapter 82, when
I realised that Griffith's last tear is frozen
- crystallised. Making it look identical to the
crystal tears that once fell from the Erdtree.
Another consistent thing in a lot
of From's games is the presence
of an enemy that should be hostile, but isn't.
And in Elden Ring, that phenomenon shows up here,
towards the end of Leyndell capital, past
a set of misbegotten. A friendly dog,
who won't attack you. No matter what you do.
Hopefully they never fix this in an update.
One thing they HAVE finally fixed though, is
the Roar medallion. It used to be that this only
buffed a few roar-effects, but now it properly
buffs a broad spectrum of attacks, including
the roar-based dragon communion incantations..
Aspect of the Crucible: Breath..
and even placidusax's Ruin.
Couple this with the highland axe,
which also buffs roar attacks and can be
simply put in your offhand, and you'll be a
force to be reckoned with. Good potential for
a roar build here somewhere now, I reckon.
For number 8 - another thing that pops up in
almost every From Software game is the presence
of a character named "Yuliya". In Demon's
Souls, it was Yuria the Witch. In Dark Souls,
it was the undead merchant who muttered this name,
talking about his sword, or perhaps the famale
undead merchant. Then Yulia was a character
in Dark Souls 3..then a major character in
Deracine..and THEN she was even a character
in Elden Ring, before the name was changed.
That's right. Go through the cut dialogue, and
you'll find lines spoken from an earlier time in
development..back when a man named "Hoarah Loux
was the Gold Mask, and when Lady Yuliya was the
name of the deathbed companion, who became Fia.
Speaking of Fia - there's something extremely
curious going on here, at the northernmost
minor Erdtree upon the Altus Plateau.
Here, an omen can be found, hunched over in
a circle with a set of commoners. But what's
weird about them, is that these are all unique
character models. The omen has a black cape,
and the commoners have a black set
with a shroud over their faces.
And it's not just the models - they have unique
casting animations as well. The commoners and
the omen are capable of casting Fia's Mist,
complete with the little smokey symbol of
death that Fia's Mist specifically, conjures up.
I guess you could speculate that these enemies are
agents of Fia, considering Fia's mist is a unique
deathblight incantation developed specifically by
her..but at the very least, they're aligned
with Godwyn's deathblight, and the new age
that his ending portends to. They're even
positioned right underneath a unique Minor
Erdtree. One that's almost entirely dead. Which
reminds me of the Shadow of the Erdtree teaser,
which might be showing Godwyn's Deathroot
clawing its way up and around the erdtree.
I wonder if this little group
is related to that. Hmm.
Anyway,
Speaking of
the Shadow of the Erdtree teaser, there are few
MORE things in that image that I wish I pointed
out earlier in my speculation video.
First is the wheat. I mentioned that
wheat is a symbol of abundance and plenty, and
theorised that it might be related to Miquella,
since he's all about abundance - and I think
this was validated even further by Quelaag,
who went into the Haligtree's prayer room
and..actually found what looks like wheat,
sticking out of a pot! Amazing find, honestly.
A few of you guys in the comments also pointed out
that a field of reeds is imagery associated with
the Egyptian afterlife, which is considered to be
the transition to the next stage of one's eternal
journey. In my speculation video, I talked about
how Miquella might be experiencing some sort
of afterlife in this image, so I love how the
egyptian afterlife imagery aligns with that.
And lastly, I didn't mention the graves,
because I didn't have much to say about
them. But a few of you guys also pointed
out that these might represent the shape of
Miquella's great rune. We don't know what
that rune looks like of course, but great runes
typically are a circle with a line through them,
so the idea that Miquella's might look like this
is a very compelling theory as well. So shoutout
to everyone involved in bringing these theoriers
to light. Turns out my 15 minute speculation video
on one image STILL didn't cover everything. Huh.
And speaking of giant dead trees and things I
never mentioned, I also never got to point out
this detail about Crucible Knight Siluria, who
stand within a giant tree at the deeproot depths.
Sometimes, very rarely - we can learn something
not just from weapons, but from the name
of their weapon arts - and the weapon art
of Siluria's Tree, is "Siluria's Woe", which
suggests that she's despairing about something.
It could be that she's lost and dejected in
the same way that so many crucible knights are,
scattered around the Lands Between
without a lord to lead them...
Or maybe, since she can be specifically found and
fought within a giant dead tree, she's despairing
about the age of the crucible that has long since
passed..and the bygone primordial Erdtree that her
weapon is modelled after. Food for thought.
In the last secrets video, I talked at length
about bell bearings, and the ball bells
that their name was likely inspired by.
We trade these bell bearings to the Twin Maiden
Husks, and since then I've been made aware that
this staff they're holding is actually
called a "Kagura Suzu", which were often
used in traditional Japanese dances, and they
consist of twelve bell balls called "suzu",
which supposedly allow one to "acquire positive
power and authority, while repelling evil".
Next comes via a tweet from Ziostorm,
who actually also does a lot of these
secret style videos, if you're
interested in watching some more.
Here, he reminds us all of the Grand
Spirit Tree Shield, which depicts the
blue spirit tree that "is said to possess divine
powers, and appears in the allegory of Quella,
the god of dream". It goes on to say that "Once
there was a boy who was easily frightened,
until the talking tree of dreamworld transformed
itself into a shield to protect him".
Obviously, the name "Quella" is just so
similar to the name "Miquella"..and as we
discussed in our Miquella lore video, Miquella
IS heavily tied to dreams and a dream world,
via their alter-ego, who is St. Trina.
I don't think there's much more here other than
From Software continuing a naming convention
they started with Dark Souls 2, but still, I
love that they keep these themes going through
the spiritual successors of all their games.
On that note, I guess we should keep an
eye out in the future for all of the other
gods listed on Dark Souls 2's name-engraved ring
But speaking of Dark Souls, I'd love to shout out
the fact that Displate have JUST launched a new
storefront FILLED with these officially-licensed
designs. And for a limited time only, you can
get 20% off if you order one or two displates,
and 30% off if you order more than
three with the link in the description.
The designs themselves are great, and I
can't wait for mine to arrive - but what
really sets all Displate apart are the metal
plates, and the printing process they use.
I've worked with Displate for a long while
for this very reason. Lemme show off some of
my own designs here so that you might see what I
mean: So despite being printed on metal, Displate
honestly match or exceed the quality of many
paper-printed samples that I've tried over the
years. The colors are rich, the blacks are deep,
and they do this all while being more durable,
and more scratch resistant, and waterproof than
many of their paper-printed competitors. They're
also easier to hang, with sticky
pads that won't damage your walls.
So if you want to show off your
love for Dark Souls in a unique,
and long-lasting way, please buy with the link in
the description. Thanks to Displate for sponsoring
this video..and let's get back to it
I reference that Miquella video a lot,
but one thing that I got wrong in that
video was regarding the Albinaurics.
Back then, I said that the Albinaurics never
once entered the presence of the Haligtree.
This was because of the Ivory Sickle description,
which states that "these weapons are evidence of
the Albinauric's dedication to the haligtree
despite never having entered its presence".
I took this to mean that no albinarics had ever
made it to the Haligtree..but that's actually
not true. Because, as pointed out by a commenter
named Vandjar, and a few others in the comments,
there are actually many first-gen albinaurics
here..they're just all inside of cocoons. Vandjar
speculates that they "seem to have died during
a process of metamorphosis, mimicking Miquella
when he sealed himself in a cucoon, and into
the Haligtree", and I like this theory. It
would make sense that these creatures, and many
others here, might hope for a rebirth, and it's
pretty fascinating to learn that this rebirth
might have been in the process of taking place.
So thanks for pointing out that
environmental detail that I missed.
Another thing I wish I had time to bring up in
that video, is that in version 1.0 of Elden Ring,
Caria was, at one stage, actually documented
as having a good relationship with Miquella.
What I'm about to read is version 1.0's
description of the Royal Guard Armor,
which eventually became Loretta's
Royal Knight Set. It reads:
"Silver armor of the Arbor Sentinels who serve
the sacred tree of Miquella, the Scion Empyrean.
Hailing from Raya Lucaria,
these enchanted knights
once belonged to the Carian
royal family, but were
later gifted to Miquella,
recipient of the Vision,
by King Consort Radagon.
The lapis blue trimmings reveal these origins.
so Radagon gifted the sentinels to miquella"
Since Radagon was involved in this gifting,
I speculate that he and Rennala were still
married at this time, which would explain why
he's making decisions on behalf of Caria here.
Also, clearly the concept of the Arbor Sentinels
was scrapped, and replaced with Loretta, who
serves a somewhat similar role - though she is
said to have left Caria of her own free will.
This description also calls Miquella the
"Recipient of the vision", which is likely
referencing a line of dialogue from Enia,
who calls Marika "the vision's vessel".
And since Miquella is an empyrean,
and worthy of becoming a god, it's likely he
was a "recipient of the vision" in the same
way that Marika was. Interesting that the Greater
Will has a "vision" for the Lands Between..but
maybe that should be the topic of another video.
Again, this is an item description that's
available on Version 1.0 of Elden Ring, and version
1.0 is..technically playable by the majority of
people - as it's just the version of the game
that is on the physical console disc if you never
update it. So unlike some other cut content,
it IS closer to the final version of the game,
and thus perhaps also the developers'
final vision for the game and the lore,
as well. And that's it! Thank you for
watching, and I'll see you next time.